hello good people whether you've arrived
at this episode of wild ride because
you're a fan of Demi Lovato or myself
trust me you are in for a treat I
honestly don't know how this happened
but boy did it and it's awesome so
ladies and gentlemen
Demi Lovato yeah hello and Demi this is
my co-host Scott who you've met numerous
times as well
how you doing yeah good to see you good
thank you
yeah so I just want to start off by
saying thank you so so much for doing
this oh my gosh absolutely
what uh like what a huge I just feel
like such a I don't know what even call
it just averman asking people to do a
podcast I just like feel like it's the
because when people have asked me
historically it's always been like God
like the most annoying question will I
do your podcast and I'm I'm thinking no
I don't want to do your [ __ ] podcast
and I made a rule if I've never heard of
the podcast the answer is no but I
always break the rule but in any case
here we are I've become what I hated and
I couldn't be more grateful to have you
oh thank you I couldn't be more grateful
to do this you've you've been supportive
to me throughout my career and you're
also just a Brad [ __ ] dude so it's
it's I'll always support in whatever way
I can and man yeah that means the world
to me so check this out with Instagram
and this would this drove me nuts for
the longest time that you can click like
followers right you know I know and
it'll like you know it'll show you a
list of people who follow you but that
list that Instagram will show you of
your followers is not in any particular
order and I always thought why the [ __ ]
does an Instagram show me my followers
in a list like by the order of how many
[ __ ] followers they have
so that I could so that I could maybe
know if like I've got big-time people
following me and I just couldn't figure
it out and I was Google searching it I
was asking people how the [ __ ] do I get
a list of my followers in the order of
the people who have the most followers
of themselves and I had a dog added
because I thought this would be a good
way to get podcast guests you know if I
could direct message someone who's
following me like you know who knows but
in any case I finally figured it out I
forget the name of the company but it
cost like three hundred and fifty bucks
and it's like a service that isn't even
like common practice but I'll totally
tell you I can maybe if you're
interested I can tell you how to sort it
out and not surprisingly when I got this
list number one on the list is Demi
Lovato
by far and they had there were they
actually generated multiple lists but
they're there there was one that was
just by the number of followers and then
there was the second list which was by
how in demand the person is and the the
in demand list was very similar to the
most followed list however it wasn't
exactly the same order there are certain
people who have less followers that are
just more in demand people but but
you're number one on both lists so thank
you and so I can only imagine you know I
should also say this wasn't how I
learned that that you follow me it's
been it's been an honor to be Instagram
friends with you for years and I
remember a time when you like didn't
follow anybody is that right like for
the first like first you know stretch on
Instagram didn't you follow 0 people
yeah I guess so I guess what happened
was I could like my team or somebody
created an Instagram for me and I never
used it
until I was doing x-factor in like 2013
maybe or 2012 I don't know so I started
using it and but I guess yeah before
that I didn't I didn't follow and right
yeah right and it was charming I'll
never forget one time it would have been
2013 you invited me to to your concert
because we both happen to be in like
okay yeah did you come with me
2013 I wasn't with okay then you weren't
with Scott but yeah I'll never forget I
came to to the concert and I kind of
tried to thought man this is this would
be cool to check it out and like
legitimately and I'm not even just like
saying this like I was like I found it
so inspiring you know like I really was
like there was just something about this
this this performance this concert that
had that just felt empowering and then
just put like you walk out of your
concert thinking I'm somebody and I can
do anything
I mean that's the whole reason why I
tour you know is to share my music with
people in person and hopefully give them
a sense of belonging in this world a
sense of community that you can relate
to the people that are in this arena
with you no matter if you know them or
not you know I just wanna that's the
whole purpose of being in this industry
it was evident it was evident and and we
and we took this picture together
remember cuz like I I would like always
be videoing and you know I'd have like a
pretty good quality camera in my pocket
and I took this picture of us together
yeah and I remember that that you posted
that photo of us on your Instagram and
the next day it was like the biggest
bump in followers I think I picked up
like 50,000 followers and and that was
like way back when when I didn't have
[ __ ] yeah I think I remember you telling
me about that
you went to the concert like you did a
prayer circle with them before remember
I remember I was like hey guys I'm like
I told her a few of my dancers and bad
members I was like yeah my friend Steve
is coming back and I I don't remember I
think I may have said Steve oh and
someone was like wait like the Stevo and
I was like what yeah there's only one
few though they're like no [ __ ] way
and I was like yeah it was awesome but I
thought I thought it was so cool that
you came back and prayed with us it's
always special when you have like a
friend come to a show because you know
when you're touring what people don't
understand is I've even had some fans
that have shown up to create several
shows in a row and I am so homesick that
like seeing a fan seeing their familiar
face is like rewarding to me and so I
seem like a friend's face is really
special and really rewarding because you
know we're touring for two three months
at a time and we're tough exhausted you
know we miss our friends our family and
so even just getting to see you that's
why I remember what city it was in cause
like I don't get a lot of visitors on
tour like especially not in Louisville
Kentucky I definitely didn't forget it
and it was it was really packed it
hadn't been completely sold out because
I remember looking at the thought oh my
god there's like 15,000 people you know
and for me I have such a different take
on touring than what you just described
because number one if I see somebody
who's who's like regularly going to show
after show after show I get super
self-conscious about that because I mean
well it's no secret that comedians
essentially do the same [ __ ] act like
over and over and over like it's almost
like supposed to be kind of mysterious
where you create the impression that
it's not just repeating the same show
and I feel I feel so exposed when I know
somebody is going to show after show
after show because they're so
interesting because with musicians
you're like the more everyone does
show the better cuz well declared
yourself singing little rides though you
don't want someone to learn your jokes
right that's the difference between you
know like you go to a comedians show the
second time and like they get if the
comedian does the same jokes they did
the last time you saw the show you're
outraged like what the [ __ ] man you
can't come back with the same show but
if you come with new stuff they're like
play the old stuff can't stop looking at
them although I do have moments where
like if I see a comedian show and they
repeat the joke I'm like oh oh wait
listen to this one this one's good right
I like tell my friends there's a little
bit of the greatest hits factor and then
you know if you had like 15,000 people
like for a really really great week the
best weekend we ever had and that's when
I say weekend we go to a city and and
it's like a comedy club and we have to
do like two shows per night two nights
in a row even though we grant we finally
graduated to theaters right before this
coronavirus [ __ ] yeah I finally
built up the momentum and I'm selling
tickets I'm sold out way before the
shows and and my agent says no more
comedy clubs for us and I'm like right
right on and then now and it's crazy
because it's such a grind
we've I've been on tour for you saved
like like two or three months at a time
I've been on tour for [ __ ] nine and a
half years there's no beginning no end
how long how long have you been touring
for like consistently are you uh you
know in 3040 weeks out of the year or do
you but then you take a break and then
you go out again so if it's like a so
the way that my career works is like if
I'm on cycle if I am doing like if I'm
in an album cycle where right now I am
finishing up my album so I'm not touring
at the moment and right everything's put
on pause do two
the pandemic and so I relate to that but
you know it's yeah I I don't have
anything coming out at this moment other
than singles and then so then so right
now I wouldn't travel as much as I do
when I tour when I to ormally put out an
album and then I tour and with that yeah
I kind of I toured two months at a time
and then I take a maybe like a couple
weeks or a month off maybe two months
and then go back out and do if it's a
world tour I'll do a different country a
different continent a month at a time
it's so funny because that's another
thing that's completely the opposite of
comedy because like a musician puts out
an album and then goes out on tour in
support of the album whereas the
comedian does the tour and then like at
the end of the tour for that material
then they record the special and put it
out it's like the the flip flop like
artists do that too I just haven't done
it yet where they filmed the concert
right like actually filmed one of my
concerts and like had it there was talk
to do that with my last tour but it just
fell through and which was a bummer
because I loved that show but yeah I see
what you're saying it is really
interesting yeah it's super interesting
and and it's a super pisser that both
models are like shut down for now but
it's all good man I the the first time
you and Steve met was that on the
staircase or was that before that the
first time that I met Demi I'm willing
to bet that just about none of you guys
would be able to guess where I met Demi
for the first time but before you find
out I want to do a couple of things I
want to tell you something very
embarrassing and I want to remind you
that with this shutdown
afros are getting big just like mine and
on top of that summer's here so balls
are getting stinky okay now here's this
embarrassing story I had this girl
friend in year 2000 and she was doing
her thing right she was a down there and
she said I'm sorry I have to stop
because it just smells too bad if you
believe that and what it was my balls so
thank God for manscaped because what do
we have here it's actual ball deodorant
okay I don't have to worry about my
balls stinking anymore because I just
put a little dab of that yeah oh yeah
yeah see and smells great
Plus that I don't have to worry about it
looking shaggy and disgusting because I
got my mower I mean dude trying try and
cut your balls with that not gonna
happen it's never gonna happen because
man escapes got it figured out and of
course I told you guys about my big
plans to have a huge harvest of bush for
a secret project that's still on and
need more do it take care of yourself
guys and here's the deal you go to
manscape calm you use the promo code
steve-o and you get 20% off your order
with free shipping again manscaped calm
that's the website you're gonna use
promo code steve-o at manscape calm for
20% off your order and free shipping if
that's not sweet I don't know what it is
but my balls smell great so I don't even
care
here we go the first time I met Demi was
when I was on Dancing with the Stars in
2009 and okay and and you know they'll
bring on like a super like super star
performer to just do like like a
performance and and it just so happened
that Demi did the performance on Dancing
with the Stars like on the week that my
niece was
visiting from Florida with my sister and
my niece was [ __ ] like maybe six at
the time like maybe then maybe seven I
don't know but she was just like she was
like oh my god that is Demi Lovato and
Jenna I was like the coolest uncle ever
for going over and saying hey and I had
never met you but I said hey like would
it be cool if you took a photo with my
niece and and damn is just like and I'm
sorry that photo of you and my niece had
on her bedroom wall
ever since and not only ever since but I
think it was your last stop in Florida
and and I somehow managed to arrange it
through a mutual rep that we have to put
her on the meet and greet list for your
last concert in Florida and and it's
like a decade later and and sure enough
my knees shows up like now 10 years
older with the same photo and you signed
it for her so now that photos on her
wall with your signature on it it's just
it's just worth mentioning because it's
so impressive to me that this like super
fandom that my niece has for you has
endured for so long you know like it's
clearly your fans have grown up with you
and like you know I came out on the
scene when I was a teenager and so they
thought well technically I was a child
because I did buy them friends but I
think wouldn't I got my break it was on
Disney Channel which is when a lot of
teeth like preteens are watching
identifying with these characters that
are the girl next door so you know they
they get that likability factor right
away and then I put out music that was
just like easy to relate to I guess and
I talked about stuff that a lot of
people were kind of leading someone to
speak about like bullying like I talked
about that I thought was something that
I dealt with and yeah I think people
really like kind of latched on
my honesty of like we need to like we
need to show this girl support and love
and make sure is like they really my fam
basis has carried me through my career
in every sense of the word whether it's
been emotional support or just like you
know success it's it's all attributed to
them because they relate and it's been
amazing I'm so grateful they have
definitely hung on for the ride
and that's super epic I saw I saw on
your Instagram that you do jiu-jitsu I
do
how long have you did have you been
doing that for and how much does it
change your life
cuz that's I'm a white belt I'm a
second-degree blue belt this is going on
here for
I'm obsessed like I love it I love it so
much and I'm missing it so much right
now but you can't have close contact
with anybody so the the most I can do is
like drills in my backyard but because I
have some mats but I just got them
yesterday so I haven't started always I
like I I've been doing it for like going
on for years it changed so much for me
because even just a way that like I use
jiu-jitsu as a metaphor to life the
techniques with jiu-jitsu are what make
you a beast you know you can you can
have you can be six five and tons of
muscle but if you're not good at
technique you're not gonna you're gonna
get put to the ground by a 65 year old
person that is better than you at
technique you know so it's like it's not
about the muscle at all and that's
what's cool of it especially for a woman
like having the confidence to walk down
an alley at night I'm not going to but
you know if you have that confidence of
like I know I can do it because if
somebody attacks me I can beat the [ __ ]
out of them and before I know I'm good
and
there's that confidence that like I've I
wish every girl could have that guy but
it has changed so much for me yeah like
I was saying with the technique sorry I
talk a lot um no I just had I'm drinking
coffee and I don't drink coffee I
started in quarantine but when you're
thinking of like sometimes it's just the
difference of an inch will make the
difference between submitting somebody
or choking them out you know like and
sometimes it's just that extra inch in
life that you need to push you towards
greatness as well and most metaphors
from jujitsu you could put into life and
I don't know I'm just like such an
advocate for I get so passionate about
it I love it and I want to talk about
MMA but there's a couple things first
you just said that about how your music
and your concerts and everything that
you do in this industry is you know
essentially to like you know sort of
give people to themselves and empower
them and you've been so prolific and
proactive with like different causes and
stuff and I know that you just did this
this new mental health fund and so I
gotta ask you about that yeah well
basically it was an opportunity that
came to me and I I could not say no to
you know it was it was totally
applicable to where everyone is right
now that we're dealing with so much
stress and anxiety with the uncertainty
of this pandemic and this is playing on
the fears of so many people and it's so
important that there's an outlet for
people especially if they're stuck at
home with their abusers or if they're
depressed and they can't get to their
therapist or their psychiatrist for some
reason you know it's just like this is a
really crucial time that people need
support and the middle Punk fund is
something that people can go to in order
to get help and where do they find a
link for that
um I'm not sure what the actual link is
I'll get that for you
and I'll make sure that we can do the
proper set we'll put it in the the
description and all that because we
definitely want to get behind that and
okay now and in in a juicier sense
quickly I'm dying to know this because
like you are so much more famous than I
am all right now before we get into this
fresh-squeezed juice let me tell you
another something that I find a little
bit embarrassing I'm self-conscious
about the fact that I used to have a
five thousand dollar mattress on my bed
up until like a month or two ago yeah
when the people from helix reached out
and told me about their sleep quiz to
determine what is the perfect mattress
for you and how they wanted me to try
out their thing and I thought you know
what my $5,000 mattress is too firm and
so I had an open mind and I and I we'd
we took the five thousand dollar thing
off the bed we stashed it in the hallway
I said let me try this out it feels good
I've really liked it but I wasn't
willing to throw away that obnoxiously
expensive mattress just yet until I felt
sure
well now it's been hmm it's been what
four four weeks five weeks and I love
this helix mattress so much that I
totally got rid of the $5,000 one I
actually gave it away to a buddy of mine
all right
and I just like honestly love it my bed
has a mattress from helix sleep comm
that's where you get it and I didn't
even know about the pillows that helix
has I'm telling you these are the most
dopest pillows ever and I'm a pillar of
psycho so I'm just thrilled about this I
had not if you go to helix sleep comm
slash Steve oh okay that's heli79 you
get up to $200 off of any mattress that
you want and
two free pillows again that is up to
$200 off of any mattress you want plus
they give you two free pillows and I'm
telling you they're the dopest pillows
in the world that's if you go to helix
sleep comm slash steve-o and you're
gonna think before it because I'm
telling you these are the greatest
mattresses and they're not obnoxiously
expensive to begin with but in any case
let's talk about how famous we are an
actual full-blown superstar definitely
the most famous friend that I have I
watched you all the time on jackass so I
don't see it that way okay everybody's
got a podcast or a little bit of credit
but you're just you're just a bonafide
superstar and and I I feel like that for
me and and I'm pretty comfortable with
it because like I'm not such a big deal
that if I like say something crazy like
it's gonna become a story or I'm not
gonna like I don't have paparazzi
chasing me around so what I'm dying to
know is like if and when you leave your
house like are there people popping out
of the bushes and like snapping photos
of you like constantly so I've gone to
the grocery store yeah I saw that a
couple times and I didn't see them so
they're actually kind of sneaky with me
I think they've learned that if they do
show themselves I'll just stop showing
up so like they literally die got this
feeling that's something that somebody
was watching anyways um so I I didn't
actually see them but then pictures
showed up later nobody actually knows
where I am right now cuz I'm not where I
was living and it's really nice because
I'm able to do stuff right now that you
know I'm not typically able to do and
it's really nice just to sit in my front
yard
and you know just not worry and it's
nice but I mean I can I like I can only
imagine what it would be like and and
I'm such an attention [ __ ] through and
through I mean every little fiber of my
being just cries out for attention and I
want so much to be like as big of a star
and as famous as I could possibly be but
I can't I can't rule out the possibility
that there's like a level where it's
like oh man why do I have to be so
famous do you ever feel that way like
there's definitely moments where I'm
like yeah I think I'm good like I don't
want to get more famous like if it gets
any worse than this I I got it like take
a step back you know they mean because
it's sometimes it's just so much to deal
with you're not nothing can prepare you
for this there's no manual there's no
like there's nothing that can that tells
you this is Fame this is what you're
gonna deal with you can't prepare and
especially on the child getting into the
industry you don't know what you're
getting into right yeah I mean there's
definitely times where I'm like uh this
is a lot but um you know I take a
day-by-day and I really don't like I
always say I don't like the same aspect
of it I like the singing so if I could
quit tomorrow and like have some sort of
Hannah Montana identity that would be my
ideal lifestyle like I would love to not
I would love to not be famous but still
get to tour and perform and it just
doesn't work like that so that's my
problem right I just want to go to
Starbucks thinking 20 photos
amongst the other way around I'm like
like I can't sing and I'm not like
particularly talented in any classic way
but I will shove things up my butt if it
will make people want to take pictures
with anyone in public
like I said that I'm not like an
attention I'm not a an adrenaline junkie
or a thrill seeker I'm just an attention
over like that's it whatever it takes
whatever it takes to get people to look
at me but it's interesting so so
speaking of being an attention when
constantly filming myself there was that
time and I think that was 2013 as well
where I like I went I went to like sex
shops in in West Hollywood and got all
this like crazy bondage gear and like
chains and like assless chaps it was a
suit made out of rubber with like a [ __ ]
mask and a zipper for the mouth and I
went around handcuffing myself to [ __ ]
so that like you know I would just be
discovered by people and it was this
parking parking garage in West Hollywood
and I had no idea I was just like okay
cool set up the cameras and I'll
handcuff myself to the railing and
whoever comes down the stairs when they
walk around this little landing all of a
sudden they'll be confronted by this
creepy [ __ ] and it wasn't even like I
did it over and over and over I did it
once and the only person down those
stairs was Demi Lovato I mean what were
you thinking when you saw that like the
last thing on your mind is that that was
gonna have to do the best reaction to
like there's a go I set up the cameras
like like a pro and there was just this
up this moment of like Florence shock
like she literally thought she was gonna
die first of all I didn't know what a
[ __ ] was like again until you said it
that like somewhere along the way that
night you said it and I was like okay I
guess that must be what this is and then
yeah I think the first thing that went
through my head was like ice kind of
slightly terrified and I and then once
that like wore off because I was like oh
he's handcuffed there's nothing you can
do I need to take a picture of this but
I didn't want to be
so I was like can I take a picture
that's why he's dressed up like right
now and I remember it's like yeah it was
just so cool of you like I was I was
like hey you know can you sign this
release form so that I can because I
wanted to be like real careful about
putting you know like put on YouTube and
and like yeah for sure like you know I
was super cool like that
I remember it's the same thing with
Justin Bieber
because I like was filming some video
I'm dressed up as a clown running around
Venice at the Venice skate park just
bumped into him like oh my god like dude
when you sign it like [ __ ] yeah for sure
like yeah and and it's interesting too
because on the topic of MMA and like I
made known like humongous fan of MMA
like I do not miss a fight I watch early
prelims starting at like 3:00 in the
afternoon and I sit there for [ __ ]
six hours like watch every single fight
and it's because like following you you
drew my attention to Ronda Rousey and I
was like let's check this out and I just
didn't even realize oh my god like I
love this and then that's why I became
such a fan of MMA right and when I was
starting to plan out like how to do a
podcast I would like I would think of
questions and write them down and and I
had this whole thing and I'm buddies
with Dana White the the president of the
UFC and I've wrote down this question
like Dana wait how come there's been
celebrity boxing there's been all kinds
of you know celebrity boxing all over
the place but there's never been
celebrity MMA like why why not and like
why don't why wouldn't they have like
the celebrity ultimate fighter you know
like and so I had that question written
down after I wrote down that question
then all of a sudden I see all
news that Justin Bieber challenged Tom
Cruise yeah fight in the Octagon and it
just so happened that like that same
exact week Dana White's assistant
reached out to me and said hey Dana
wants to invite you to be at the season
premiere for the contender series here
in Vegas do you want to come and I said
I said [ __ ] yeah I want to come and like
can I get Dean on camera for a minute
what I'm there yes they said for sure
let's ride this [ __ ] event I get Dean
in the band he has no idea what I want
to ask him and I said to Dana White Dana
I I've watched this as news about about
Justin Bieber and Tom Cruise and I think
Tom Cruise is afraid of Justin Bieber
but I'm here to tell you that I am not
afraid and I asked him what he put on a
fight between me and Justin Bieber
because I wanted to raise money so my
girl and I can start our own animal
sanctuary and and Dana White said I
entered the [ __ ] out of this whole thing
I mean put it out as a video on YouTube
and it's so heavily to cut out like 90%
of the conversation which was Dana White
wanting nothing to do with it whatsoever
he was like dude I don't know what
Commission would put that on you know
like like it wouldn't be legal you know
[Music]
okay so there was one time where I was
text I was trying to put on the fight
and it was right when they switched from
UFC fight pass to ESPN but Fox yeah so I
was like trying to figure it out and I
was so used to like just going to the
fight pass out and hooking up the fights
that way and then all of a sudden now
there's all these extra steps and I
couldn't figure it out so I instagrammed
on my Instagram story I posted like what
what's the point of UFC fight pass now
like if you can't even watch the fights
on it because I I'm trying and I'm about
to miss like some really good fights
like that like right like I'm getting
like frustrated because I can't get it
to work and all of a sudden I get this
text
with like instructions and it says like
go to espn.com slash done it and it's
got the instructions and I and I go I
just reply was like thanks but who is
this and you fight it stayin away from
the UFC [ __ ] I'm so sorry
never Instagram story about you
obviously not working because you will
get a text from saying away no that
would be awful
hey real quick
who's your favorite MMA UFC fighter you
know I'm gonna go with Rosie see I love
DC but I also love a friend of mine
named Emily wittmeyer she's trained me
several times and she's just she's a
badass I love her as a person and I
don't know I know a lot of fighters and
I'm friends with the bunch but she's a
good friend of mine and I have a lot of
love for her so I would say her good
yeah I don't know I mean there's there's
time to show any yes there's so many
different types of fighters too right
so as far as like just nice like I would
say Dustin Poirier it's just such a nice
just good dude such a classy dude math
with all the sweetheart massive Maz
Mehnaz our buddy that's I don't know him
Thoros I've never met her or anything
but I just like to wear on Instagram I
did she's she's so [ __ ] cool yeah
she's a badass hi man when they had UFC
249 was supposed to be back on and it
was just like the main events from all
of these ones that got canceled it was
the craziest card ever and then it
didn't happen it's not let's not
alienate people who aren't fans of MMA
let's try it let's try that thing can we
get
can you look that way a little bit just
just look that way
okay I'm not like I'm gonna look that
way okay mm a little bit more towards me
I can't yes yeah right there
now just keep looking that way and
answer this question what do you call a
lesbian dinosaur to lick a lot of puss
yeah okay so what so what else do we got
I was a big one how about acting like
you started us and likes acting and and
I've heard you talk so much about
singing are we done with acting yeah
absolutely I have a movie coming out
Kualoa soon I don't know the exact date
but I have a movie coming out with Will
Ferrell and Rachel McAdams
it's called Eurovision and it's a comedy
I'm so excited about it I've always
wanted to work with the two of them and
now I get to do it in the same movie and
so I and I actually shot my 20 my first
day of shooting was on my 27th birthday
yes the last time I filmed something on
my birthday was I believe it was Camp
Barack the first day of production of
Camp Rock so that was that was kind of
cool
felt like a new beginning what was it
about Camp Rock that was so much bigger
than all the other projects I think that
was just like such a big deal but you
weren't like regularly on the Disney
Channel before that right no so Camp
Rock was my firt well I've done one
thing for Disney Channel before that and
it was called as the bell rings it was
like this many show that were it was
five-minute episodes and they would play
these commercial breaks so I did it was
like not many people knew of it but then
I booked Camp Rock and immediately after
started filming my TV show so the sunny
one yes sunny was chance so yeah yeah I
wish I it was just like I don't know um
it was my my first big gig but I think
also because it was acting and music it
was double the gotcha gotcha that's
right okay so that that makes sense
because you have like my song the songs
from the movie were on the iTunes chart
back when they had iTunes and it was
like it was on the iTunes chart but then
it was also because it was film and it
were made-for-tv movie it was I had my
face on stuff as well so you go into
target and I see my face on like a beach
towel so rad so jealous that's your
dream
that reminds me that the last time I
bumped into you in person like dude you
maniac like I'm a maniac I was like hey
do you have your air drop on like I've
got that I'm just excited about this and
I air dropped over I'm sweating why I'm
even saying this but I air dropped over
on to Demi's phone like unreleased [ __ ]
that like like - do you remember that
know like the most like the most high
level [ __ ] epic [ __ ] how long ago was
this not that long ago I mean it was
clearly after we filmed the opening
sequence - gnarly okay right oh my god
wait I wish but like I had known it was
so top secret I did still not fair to
people it's still not out and and it's
an hour now or maybe like two or three
weeks maybe away from from putting it
out and yeah it's the first time that
there was a full jackass cast reunion
since we last Ryan Dunn and it was the
first time we had all
together everybody and all the guys
duct-taped me to the [ __ ] side of a
billboard truck with my name on it and
just just almost [ __ ] kill me while
I'm duct-taped to this this truck and
then my buddy Preston literally drives
the truck with me taped to the side of
it like all the way to Las Vegas yeah
and then we picked up the second half of
it in the snow-covered mountains of
Colorado and filmed the Sun coming up
and because I taped the special in in
Denver yeah so like she didn't even know
it's on her phone sweetheart Wendy wait
I also airdrop to you the video of me
finding this dog right here Wendy from
Peru yes I can't wait to me girl that's
a girl yeah she might appear to be dead
or unwell but what she does is she just
matches my speed like if I get up and
run she gets up and run if I sit and
chill she said some chills like she's I
found her in the streets of Peru like I
tried to smuggle her into my hotel in
Peru and they wouldn't allow it
so I so I pitched a tent outside of the
hotel and slept with her in the tent for
like the next five nights before we went
up into the mountains and she followed
me everywhere for the whole three weeks
and she's my girl yeah it's a Cinderella
nice nice I love it I love it how are
you keeping busy during the pandemic are
you staying busy do you have a routine
do you keep a ritual or you're just kind
of chillin you know I'm really enjoying
the downtime
I was supposed to be like hitting the
ground running going back to work but
the way that everything happened the
world kind of paused and it's been
really nice and it's been a blessing in
disguise because I'm like I'm super
grateful that I like have you know the
ability to release new music and
everything but it's just really nice
being able to spend time with family
getting to focus on like my mental
health as well right now I'm doing a lot
of meditating yeah yeah like and I swear
I haven't meditated so much of my life
like me too yeah because there's you
find yourself there's literally nothing
to do so you might as well do nothing
you know so what kind of meditating do
you do um sometimes I'll do like guided
prayers there's an app on my phone
our church has and so I'll do diet guide
guided prayers other meditations will be
like I do some Kundalini okay and some
is just like breathing nice I'm on a
tear I keep it um on an app as well and
I'm today was day 117 straight of
averaging over 40 minutes a day because
I dude 20 minutes twice a day I know and
I really like have this I probably
shouldn't say cuz I don't want to like
jinx it but I I just genuinely have a
belief that by the virtue of like being
disciplined about a meditation practice
that the universe conspires in my favor
somehow I just believe that I for sure
by setting a time by setting a sign I
set aside time by setting aside time to
like really make an effort to connect
with God is what it is you know that the
universe God like like that effort I
think is somehow recognized and like the
and there's this this
[ __ ] this legit thing we're just things
kind of come into place you know totally
it's almost like the universe is
watching you put hard work into yourself
and it wants to reward you I'm like I
believe that meditation is hard work
that's why so many people don't do it
they just show up they use the exist
which is the excuse I used to use which
was I'm not good at meditating or like
I'm too distracted like well it's like
that's the whole purpose like that's why
you're so dirty it's to like practice oh
my god that's why it's called to
practice huh I feel like people are like
oh well gardening's my meditation it's
like no no that's gardening meditation
is meditation you know right why do you
have anything else because I think that
we've probably how long we've been going
with 44 minutes I think we could
probably cut Demi loose yeah we really
appreciate I'm dying to know who does
your eyebrows those are the best looking
eyebrows I've ever seen in my entire
life
thank you I actually do them I don't let
anybody touch them I'm the best looking
eyebrows I've ever seen in my life what
I do want to ask like like that there
are there any TV shows that I'm not
aware of that I need to start watching
like [ __ ] immediately so I I haven't
been watching a lot of TV shows but I
have been watching movies and I just saw
this movie that I think you'll really
love called Close Encounters of the
fifth kind is that like a super old one
no it's not it's a brand new documentary
and it was just released this in April
so yeah I was just released on Apple TV
but it's all about actually meditation
and okay the well technically it's about
aliens but you they talk about how you
can have a close encounter of the fifth
prime which is the fifth of contact with
aliens so that the close encounters
would be like the first encounter would
be like seeing a UFO the second would be
like some kind of proof being left
behind the third and
honor would be like like you have some
sort of interaction with the alien the
for a cause like you're on board you get
abducted and then the fifth is like
human initiated contact with aliens
I found nuts right I love it I think
there's a correlation between you know
the shift in the Mayan calendar where it
was like where everyone said the world
was gonna end in 2012 all that people
had like people had said for a long time
there was gonna be the shift in
consciousness I really think that was
the beginning of it
Jorund this documentary is talking about
that shift of consciousness and I think
that like it's just also interesting
that it was one of the top viewed movies
on an Apple TV they give it some the top
most watched and I think this time right
now is forcing a lot of people to like
look within themselves and that
consciousness is totally shifting so I
think you'd really like it and I want to
hear your thoughts at text me out okay
yes maybe tags how it's cops Close
Encounters of the fifth kind yeah okay
yeah and what about books like do you
have a favorite book I'm so ADHD I do
not read okay good yeah I just don't I'm
pretty bad about it but I gotta tell you
the conversations with God book 1 like
really spoke to me and you know I have
that and I get it on audiobook and do it
while you work out it's so much easier
conversations with God book 1 I read it
in 2009 and it was I wasn't quite ready
for it I reread it in 2017 and it just
clicked and I was like oh my god and it
changed the way I look at absolutely
everything and I read in 2017 the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ]
whoo and that one's good too okay I like
that I like that I did it a little bit
but I don't like I wouldn't call myself
a reader I
and and one last question we'll let you
go but an album recommendation I my
go-to album is continuum John Mayer oh
yeah yeah okay good to know that that's
good because here's the thing
like with with music like there's
there's something so special about music
where like whether whether you like it
or don't like it it doesn't matter but
if you're familiar with it
then it serves as like a record for your
experience in life so if you hear music
that that you haven't listened to in a
long time it'll take you back to that
time when you did hear it and so I like
to be deliberate about recording you
know periods of my life to music you
know so yeah for sure 100% and like so
so with that in mind I have this this
habit which I really don't do enough but
I'll take one album and I'll just listen
to it on a loop on a loop and a loop
eneloop and a loop like for like even
like days or weeks on end so then I'm
investing in down the road in the future
whenever I hear that like it's gonna
conjure up this like this feeling of
that time and so I'd like to ask for
album recommendations so that I can do
that proactively and John Mayer just got
a big a big shameless plug I got a song
out with Sam Smith called I'm ready and
then I don't have a song out called I
love me okay good
how do we wait until this this deep into
is there anything else that you want to
promote no that's good okay so so I love
me
and once I said II and I'm ready okay
good and yeah and I wanted like this is
I think in recent time
the album that I was most rewarded by
Biden playing on a loop is when we were
touring Europe and it was an album that
my buddy Bam Margera made and like he
sings on the whole album and like he
just got like this like sort of cast of
great musicians to put it all together
called the eavesdroppers so like that
and I just [ __ ] loved it
I can't tell bamming up I'm like that
[ __ ] eavesdroppers album is
incredible but I but yeah and then what
is it John Mayer what stimula continuum
is it does it have like hit songs that
I'll know from the radio yeah your cue I
think the album cuts on that album are
what make it gold album cut they helped
mold the album into the body of work
that it is okay good good all right well
then I'm gonna add to my to my iTunes
which I still use iTunes is my thing I'm
gonna buy your songs and I'm gonna buy
John Mayer's continuum album and I'm
gonna remember this this [ __ ] shut
down forever right for sure and I just
want to say again thank you so much damn
you like it is such a humongous favor
that you've done for me to do this it's
just really really I appreciate it
I'm sure that everybody else does as
well and I'm not going to be the the
[ __ ] [ __ ] who's who asks the favor
of recording the parties and then turns
around says oh hey will you post about
it that's the worst when they double
whammy I'm sure won't even need any
promotion and it's been fantastically
entertaining and all of my love from
from from Wendy and and and everybody
really appreciate you thank you so much
even bigger thanks to you the people who
are still hanging in there this deep
into the podcast I love you guys so so
much and as I've always done on every
single episode I've asked you guys to
put a screenshot to let me know that you
actually got this far and post it and
the people who do that I call my street
team and to date there is not one tweet
not one Instagram post with a screenshot
of my podcast that I have not double
tapped hit the like on I [ __ ] dig it
dude I dig it my street team so if you
guys listen to this
thank you and extra thinks if you're on
the street team and I'll hit up that
post cool man
take care guys well